buenos días o buenas tardes o lo que sea
donde te encuentres donde quiera que
estés viendo este vídeo
en fin me han pedido que haga una lista
de vídeos sobre probabilidad y creo que
es un excelente idea
así es que voy a iniciar esta lista de
vídeos sobre probabilidad que bueno que
estamos haciendo esto proba probabilidad
probabilidad yo no hago vídeos sobre
deletrear probabilidad que es esto todos
de alguna manera tenemos una idea de lo
que es probabilidad es algo informal y
hasta donde yo sé no hay una definición
formal de lo que es una probabilidad hay
varias definiciones casi formales
compitiendo entre sí así por poner un
ejemplo cotidiano si el hombre del clima
dice que hay un 50 por ciento de
posibilidad de lluvia para mañana
básicamente está dando una probabilidad
lo que le está diciendo y bueno hay
varias maneras de interpretar lo que
este 50% de probabilidad significa una
podría ser que si cien por ciento es que
estás seguro de que va llover mañana y 0
por ciento es que está seguro que no va
a llover mañana entonces
ese 50% significa que está por así
decirlo neutro entre esas dos
posibilidades entonces una definición
podría ser que tan fuerte que tan fuerte
es su creencia de hecho hay toda una
escuela de probabilidad que ve la
probabilidad de esta manera se llama
bayesianas abordaremos esto con más
detalle posteriormente cuando hacemos
problemas fáciles las distintas
perspectivas son prácticamente lo mismo
pero posteriormente veremos cuál es la
diferencia otra manera interpretar la
probabilidad es la que tiene la escuela
frecuente y sta si se tienen datos
acerca del fenómeno por ejemplo si el
hombre del tiempo tiene datos acerca de
la nubosidad también quizá cuenta con
lecturas de barómetro y también sale a
lo mejor en qué etapa se encuentra la
luna entonces dada esa gran cantidad de
datos y siempre que se cuente con
exactamente ese mismo tipo de
información 100 veces entonces en 50
veces o el 50 por ciento de las veces
a job eso entonces esta visión considera
dado toda esa cantidad de datos que se
tiene y si tuvieras esos datos 100 veces
si fueras capaz de repetir ese
experimento 100 veces aunque va a ser
muy difícil que obtengas exactamente el
mismo tipo de datos que martes está en
el lugar adecuado las emisiones solares
y todo eso es muy probable que se tenga
el mismo tipo de información ya sabes el
efecto mariposa una mariposa puede
afectar el viento sobre el océano es muy
probable realizar el mismo tipo de
experimento 100 veces pero lo que el
hombre el tiempo estaría diciendo es que
si se tuviera el mismo tipo de datos 100
veces en 50 de esas veces o el 50 por
ciento de esas veces tendríamos lluvia
al día siguiente aquí lo que se tendría
entonces es que el 50 por ciento de los
experimentos 50 por ciento de los
experimentos con las mismas y creo que
podríamos decir condiciones iniciales
medibles y esto lo estoy haciendo sobre
la marcha
no hay que tomarlo como verdad absoluta
sin embargo yo creo que te da la idea
con las mismas condiciones iniciales
va a resultar en lluvia son casi la
misma cosa pero como veremos
posteriormente los frecuentes estás y yo
tiendo a ver el mundo también de esta
manera pero en la gran mayoría de los
casos cambia mucho las circunstancias
por lo cual es muy difícil que puedas
decir que realizaste exactamente el
mismo experimento varias veces por
ejemplo en 2003 si alguien decía que hay
un 50 por ciento de posibilidad 80 por
ciento de posibilidad de que sadam
husein tuviera armas de destrucción
masiva eso yo pienso que sería una
probabilidad tú sabes están estos
analistas de la cia que no pueden ser
influenciados por sus jefes diciendo no
podemos estar totalmente seguros pero
pensamos que hay un 80 por ciento de
probabilidad ellos se ubicarían en esta
perspectiva de acuerdo porque en
realidad no podrías hacer este mismo
experimento 100 veces no hay 100
oportunidades o mil oportunidades o un
grano de oportunidades donde tengas
exactamente las mismas circunstancias
con ese tipo del gran bigote en el medio
oriente dándole la vuelta a los
inspectores de armas en fin vayamos a
otra cosa esto que hemos
esto aquí es muy sutil pero nos da la
diferencia entre estas dos perspectivas
aunque es sutil nos da un muy buen marco
de referencia sobre lo que es la
probabilidad hagamos algo de notación de
hecho buscando en wikipedia encontré
esta definición quizás no fue wikipedia
fue otro sitio web de hecho creo que es
una definición que es bastante común
donde establecen que la probabilidad del
evento a algunas veces escribe como pda
así que la probabilidad de que a ocurra
es igual a el número de eventos o más
bien los eventos aquellos eventos
donde a es verdadera sobre el número
total de eventos y está para la mayoría
de los casos es una muy buena definición
sin embargo te mostraré un caso donde
esto no es tan claro entonces si te digo
que voy a echar un volado y no mejor
pensemos en tirar un dado y digamos que
queremos la probabilidad y voy a ir
directamente hacer problemas más
difíciles digamos entonces que queremos
la probabilidad de un número par bueno
usemos esta definición para ver que nos
da entonces cuáles son los eventos donde
esto es verdad veamos cuáles son los
números que obtenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 es tan
solo un dado normal no es de esos que se
usan en el cubilete entonces en cuáles
eventos obtenemos un número par aquí los
tenemos
voy a marcarlos con rojo es el 2 el 4 y
el 6 tres eventos en tres eventos es
verdad de lo que sea par tenemos 3
dividido entre el número total de
eventos que son 63 entre 6 y esto es
igual a un medio o también 50 % de
acuerdo ya sabemos cómo convertir
fracciones a porcentajes y este
resultado es correcto es perfectamente
correcto sin embargo sólo lo puedes
aplicar lo cual es válido en la mayoría
de los problemas que te ponen en la
escuela pero solo puedes aplicar se
asume que todos los eventos tienen la
misma probabilidad de ocurrir podría
darse el caso en que tuvieras un dado o
varios dados podría darse el caso en que
ese dado de seis lados está cargado es
decir pesa más hacia un lado alguien lo
manipuló y quizá es más probable que te
salga un 3 o cualquier otro número pero
en ese caso no vas a poder usar esta
definición así es que voy a modificar
esta definición aunque no sé si
tradicionalmente se modifica en vez de
que diga eventos donde a es verdadero
sobre el número total de eventos vamos a
ponerlo como igualmente probables
eventos igualmente probables donde a sea
verdadero dividido entre el total de
eventos
igualmente
probables así que para que esto sea
verdadero estas 6 circunstancias tienen
que tener exactamente la misma
oportunidad de ocurrir y vamos a hacer
quizás no en este vídeo porque solo me
quedan 3 minutos pero en esta serie te
voy a mostrar situaciones donde tienes
quizás un dado cargado o un conjunto de
circunstancias donde todos y cada uno de
los eventos no son igualmente probables
es por eso que quise hacerte un poco
consciente de esta situación con eso en
mente
hagamos un par de problemas más que nos
den y tuición acerca de robots acerca de
lo que pasa en este mundo de la
probabilidad así si estoy echando un
volado y me pregunto cuál es la
probabilidad de que caiga águila bien es
bastante fácil puede usar la definición
pues es una moneda legal aplicando
entonces la definición el número total
de eventos que tenemos son dos águila o
sol y queremos la probabilidad de águila
que es uno de esos dos eventos hay un
medio de probabilidad la manera en la
que a mí me gusta ver esto sin tener que
usar
definición es si voy a realizar este
experimento cien veces cuál es el
porcentaje de esas veces en las que es
más probable que yo obtenga un águila
por lo cual mi respuesta sería el 50 por
ciento de las veces voy a obtener
águilas y para esto puedo tener un
argumento de simetría esto es que es
igualmente probable obtener soles que
águilas la razón por la cual yo
esperaría 51 águilas o 49 soles aunque
eso podría suceder por una razón para la
cual yo expreso águilas y soles son
igualmente probables cualquiera de los
lados de la moneda es igualmente
probable que caiga en fin ahora
supongamos que tiene un volado con la
misma moneda dos veces voy a tirar el
volado voy a levantar la moneda y vuelvo
a tirar el volado y cuál la probabilidad
de que obtenga
águila
y águila así que esta es la probabilidad
de obtener águila el primer volado y
águila en el segundo volador veamos lo
de la siguiente manera en el primer
volado ya sabemos que tenemos el 50 por
ciento de probabilidad o un medio de
probabilidad de obtener un águila en el
primer volado veámoslo desde el punto de
vista frecuente esta si yo tiro 100
veces un volado 50 veces voy a obtener
alguien en el primer volado le llamaré
águila 1 y 50 veces voy a obtener sol en
el primer volado de acuerdo estamos
entonces en este punto de nuestro
experimento y lo vamos a repetir de
acuerdo así que de estas 50 veces qué
porcentaje de las veces va a caer águila
de nueva cuenta de estas 50 que nosotros
ya tuvimos aquí puede tener águila o sol
un 50 por ciento va a ser para que sea
águila y otros 50 por ciento para que
sea sol pero bueno habían sido 50 el 50
por ciento de 50 va a ser 25 por ciento
simplemente multiplique estos dos
números entonces lo mismo para este caso
aquí tendríamos 25 por ciento esto va a
ser
águila águila águila sol y lo mismo pasa
cuando sacamos sol en la primera
instancia sol águila va a tener una
probabilidad del 25 por ciento también
hizo el sol también del 25 por ciento
bueno se me acabó el tiempo nos vemos en
el próximo vídeo